[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum how are you guys
plugging away are things getting a
little better I hope so I hope you're
you know you're doing your thing doing
your routine I was thinking I last
week's episode I thought it was dynamite
I thought dr. drew was terrific I hope
you enjoyed that you'll learn a lot I
mean he gives some valuable tips and I
find it really humble humbling humble I
find it nice when a doctor as
established as you know dr. juste pretty
established I mean he's got a history of
you know success and but when he opens
up about his anxiety that was that was
really cool and it was just nice it was
nice to hear I think I got a lot of
great comments about it how would help
people just taking more vitamin D ah man
I'm a big fan of the movie the Warriors
it's a horror movie but no sorry it's a
freaking action movie it's a it's a gang
in New York I don't know why I was
thinking hard cuz I love horror so much
but it's my dad and I it's our favorite
movie in fact for Father's Day you know
I got him a bunch of warrior stuff well
I was I was looking online for 20 years
I've been looking for an original
warrior's vest you know one of the vests
that the war years wore in the movie an
original I wanted my I knew it was
impossible I've been looking for one for
I don't know how many years but and
there was one available worn by this
yeah the actor was David Harris Cochise
was the character loved that character
had the bandana he was on the couch with
the Lizzie's remember I don't know if
you saw but you she's watching his
classic it's cold it's awesome but here
it is you can't see it if you're
listening you'll have to go home and
watch but it's an original dude it says
it says Cochise on the top right here
near the collar it's it's phenomenal I'm
I'm ecstatic about it
I just wanted to tell you that so
there's some good news you know a lot of
great guests coming up and I appreciate
you listening trying to build this
listenership and I notice when people
are a fan of some ones that come and
they listen to that person in it you
know you try to get them to stick around
hopefully they'll like the interview
enough to subscribe and listen so when
you guys write reviews and you email
your friends and text your friends and
tell them to subscribe it really helps
all that helps I know I talk about it
every episode but you have to if you you
want more people to listen or maybe it
turns people off I don't know Robin I
did a staged it last week I hope you
enjoyed it it was a lot of fun we
performed some new songs some covers a
couple left on Laurel songs for the band
by the way the left on Laurel album our
album from November that came out of
still around you could buy the album on
inside of you online store you could
listen to it on Spotify you could buy it
on iTunes it's all great and you know we
play songs here at the end of the
episode each time Ryan plays something
no news right now in camp rosy like
summer camp we're gonna do a Halloween
thing on October 31st adult summer camp
we'll see how this whole luck Cova thing
goes July 2nd live podcast with Zack
Levi at the North door in Austin two
shows we're waiting to hear what happens
with that so hold on your horses you
know wanted to say a big shout out I
always give a shout out the end of the
episode in the answer to all my patrons
but want to say hello to all my patrons
for inside of you who keep this show
going period and also my new patreon
exclusive a horror club if you want to
call it with Jon Heder and I'm Napoleon
Dynamite we have a horror Club where we
watch movies and everybody watches with
us and it's a blast so it's called where
have all the good horror movies gone you
could find that on patreon and join us
and it's it's a really fun I think John
and I have a really fun dynamic and I
think you're gonna dig it we message
everyone and it's a community it's a
book club
I don't like books but it's watching
horror movies instead
today's guest is one of my favorite of
all time she was on the podcast before
people said when is she coming back she
hasn't really been on video on the
podcast she was just uh you could listen
to her first one
which is awesome this one I think is
even better we get into it and she opens
up more and about her family and her
life and um she's uh she's not old but
she's been around people know who she is
and I'm excited to talk with her again
talk to her again I can't speak maybe
I'm just a little nervous but why don't
we get inside of jennifer Love Hewitt
it's my part of you you're listening to
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hi how are you I'm just great what a
terrible way to start hi how are you I
am good how are you I'm doing fine it's
uh you know it just takes I think I'm
starting like it's not like you get ever
get used to this but III the first two
weeks I was having anxiety attacks you
know me I was having you know but not
full flesh because I've been working on
myself so you know as long as I just
wasn't on my routine so it felt like
okay this is gonna end this is gonna be
this is a joke this is gonna be a week
and then we're fine because who could
nobody could imagine there's one of my
friends James Gunn you know guardians of
the galaxy director I'm gonna draw
here's what you do Jennifer you just
drop it when you drop a name is Jeff you
know but I remember like he was ahead of
it he was way ahead and it's just hard
for people to believe that early that
okay this is really the way the world is
gonna work and so no one could have
predicted this but you know I have to
give James credit he knew early on and I
mean since it May 15th I've been except
for three grocery visits I've been
locked up in this house I've been here
for a year I new gun news eight months
ago
no but it's easy when you not easy it's
better when you stick to your routine if
you don't exercise your EFT if you don't
keep a decent diet your EFT if you don't
have activities your EFT if you don't
watch shows if you just stand your
computer and watch CNN or whatever the
hell you watch out there
your EFT you have to change things or
you will fall apart yeah I just with the
working out part of it because I have to
you three and a half or four hours of
school with my daughter every day and
then when I'm done with that I had to go
do at least a couple of hours with my
son and then it's like lunchtime and
then I've just been I've been very hyper
focused on me keeping them okay during
this time
my husband okay during this time that I
had kind of not been as good to myself
and so this week is like the first week
where I was like you know my family I
love you guys I'm gonna do everything
for everybody but I've got to like give
myself some space to take care of myself
because I was starting to have really
bad anxiety attacks again so I just want
a peloton bike it's on its way I'm gonna
start doing that which I'm excited about
and getting some sunshine and just
trying to like just take better care of
myself yeah I got one of those I finally
won't get one of those bikes in Ashkelon
which is amazing and it's like you're
you're riding and you're you're seeing
the you know I'm in four hundredth place
this is great you know I know I can't
increase the speed I can't by the way I
never biked in my life here's here's
things that I haven't done I really
never run ran I've never run ran I'm not
a runner because I play sports and I get
bored and also I've had a bad back issue
so running the impact as bad so I never
run ever and I've never ridden really
bikes except when I was a kid so to get
on this bike the first thing I know
notice is that my ass crack really hurts
me like when you get one of those bikes
why don't they make the seats I hear
that you get used to it it's like your
taint can I use the word taint yeah you
you get used to it I guess that area of
your butthole or what is that is your
taint isn't that what do you call that
there's got to be a better name than
taint no I don't know I I I was never a
runner either because I've bad knees
together we're all native and I actually
have never learned to ride a bicycle
about me that people don't know I tried
when I was a kid and I had a really bad
experience with my stepdad he didn't
mean to but he kind of made me feel bad
and not so bright for not being able to
ride a bike and like completely scarred
me so I never got back on a bike again
but I just bought myself a shway
in adult tricycle an adult tricycle
three wheels I love it and I can't wait
to get my training wheels up that would
be a fun thing too just like today that
your training wheels come off to be
there to document it will you call me
I'll come over I'll just watch
Jennifer's Ticknor four wheels just like
power on their bikes but they are so
supportive and they root me on and they
love that I'm trying and learning
something at my very you know old age
and it's cute alright Jess my assistant
goes ask her about her pink hair now
I'm color blind and if you wouldn't have
said anything I would have just said oh
I would not have noticed I don't see
pink but it is a little pink I guess
right because that's what you told me in
bright pink I dated a girl she was a
dancer and she had this really rich pink
hair but it was noticeably like I go
whoa that's like a that's like cotton
candy her I like it I think it's cool
who's cuttin your hair looks like you
just got a trim too who cut your hair
you cut your own hair didn't you wait a
minute your before
well looks freshly cut thank you so much
you just seem like it you're in a pretty
good way right now I know your Instagram
is a pretty dope I've in fact want to
play one if I may because you're you're
you know addressing the importance of
supporting small businesses at this time
which is vital you know all those little
places that we like all these places
that we go to we're not going to go
there anymore if we don't support them
and that's just the way it is I know
it's been really fun actually I didn't
realize I guess I just never really
thought of them as small business owners
but I didn't realize how many friends
and people that I I'm close with who
have you know really built their
businesses from the ground up and it's
been really it's been really hard to
watch them hurt and go through all that
they've been going through and this time
and so I just wanted to do some things
so yeah we started this little like
Instagram thing called big loan for
small business and I've just allowed
them to come on and it's been really
great like some of them have seen
a big increase in people like reaching
out to them and buying their stuff for
supporting them during this time and you
know I I just we see a lot about the
bigger businesses on TV but it's all the
small business really that is like the
heart of a city I feel like it's like
those are the places means something to
people and have your you know you've had
memories there or you those are the
people that remember like oh your son is
turning five right and you're like how
do you remember that you know and
they're just like really invest in
people and so I just wanted to invest
back in them really nice little
restaurant called poach a it's in the
Hills because we you and I when you and
I were supposed to do this movie that
just fell apart oh my god let's not get
into that called sorry is for sissies
and it was such a fun script and we
would have rained it got such a great
cast involved and like independent
movies you lose the money and then you
fall apart and you smoke a pack of
cigarettes and you feel like [ __ ] but
poce you know it's definitely suffering
in my buddy che over there it's like you
know I think they still have delivery
and had the best food ever ever the
cedar planked fish so you got an order
and you got to tell your friends hey try
to keep this keep this place go there's
places like that all over so I love that
you're doing that and have you had
breakdowns have you had like a real
breakdown like were you like oh my god
that was an ugly one and it was in front
of everyone like well everyone meaning
you're Atticus and autumn and your
husband for stuff like three hours
crying last I had a dance party like I
just felt myself sort of
short-circuiting like everything that
you can feel all happen at once today if
I'm being totally honest I have been in
an anxiety attack since pretty much 8:30
this morning do you want to cancel I
just did like a little meditation thing
for what do you do what do you do I have
crystals that really mean a lot to me
that are that I just feel like holds
good energy and so I usually like lay
down and I lay them on my heart in my
chest and my stomach and like one on my
head just kind of wherever I'm feeling
like
that helps yeah it does for me it does
because it just kind of forces me to say
self is there on me and I don't want
them to break and so it just kind of
makes me stop and I don't know I just
usually start by like doing like 10
minutes of just everything that's good
in my life I'm not I'm really grateful
for to remind myself that this the thing
that's like eating at me is smaller or
than good yeah so that I feel like
regroup my sauce you know yeah yeah it's
been it's it's just a difficult it's a
difficult times
I just miss people you know you and I
are very similar and I really enjoy
people being around people I think we
also enjoy being in our houses enjoying
our chef but I I miss me and this the
ability to be around people and I really
hurt for my kids like I just hate
watching them not know when they're ever
gonna see their kids again and I don't
know how to explain it to them yeah I
don't know I miss my mother-in-law she's
in Maryland and she's like by herself
right now and you know it's just hard
it's just a scary it's a scary time but
then I think about I think about like us
being able to sit here and have this
conversation and we're not doctors and
nurses who haven't left like yeah
Hospital and also and also like you know
I always say this but it's like we're
entitled to we can say if we're having
anxiety we're you know we're human
beings but you know we all you but you
put things into perspective you know I
was talking to Dave Bautista another
name drop sorry but Dave Dave was like
you know you put things into perspective
it's like you know the homeless just
when you think it couldn't get worse for
homeless people it does and just all
these people are starving losing their
jobs unemployment rates all it's just
and like I'm sitting here going I'm
[ __ ] grateful I'm lucky all I could
do is share my podcast and get insight
from other people and what they're going
through and what they do and for a
second I was gonna stop you when you
said you put crystals on your chest
because I sort of wanted to defend it in
a way not that you were being persecuted
but you know there's gonna be haters out
there like all crystals and these actors
and then it's like here's what I say
[ __ ] off because whatever works for you
the proverbial you will Jennifer myself
well I don't care what it is I don't
care if it's running naked through a
jungle
we're having crystals on your chest or
meditating whatever it is maybe we come
out of this more understanding more
accepting more loving more like holy
[ __ ] like affection is so important
we're not we're not able to do that
right now so I hope that at least we get
something because sometimes these
feelings of like you know when someone
dies that you love that's Karina like a
an actor oh my gosh and and that two
days later you're on to the next thing
people it's it's ephemeral right it's
like it doesn't last long I hope this
lingers not to dwell on it but I hope
people just say gosh look how lucky we
already we're at a restaurant having
dinner together or we're taking a hike
together or we're hugging or f'ing I
throw the effing in there the reason
that it's a crystal is because they're B
I mean they're just beautiful and I just
think they're beautiful I collect them I
think they're they're gorgeous I don't
keep them on I don't put them on me as
like a like some far-out universe moment
like I put them on me because they're
bigger and greater than I am I'm I am
NOT any saying that simple and not
beautiful and not like you know but and
and it just brings me comfort and I
think they hold good energy for me
personally but but I recommend for
anybody even if you don't want to use
Christmas the teddy bears put chocolate
bars first of all is it a is it taboo to
give crystals that you're using to
someone else to use or should you always
give new crystals everyone should have
their own crystal that's their thing
because I was gonna say hey I'd love for
you to either egg put me in the right
direction to get the right crystals or
maybe send me some crystals that I could
start with like a crystal starter kit or
maybe just not crystal meth and be gosh
I just felt like the name loves crystals
you could just start your elemental
crystal world of amazing places that I
can tell you to go and look for them I
don't think that you're supposed to
share
you can hold your energy but because I'm
starting you off maybe I will pick one
that I really love and send it to you as
I hear some of my energy to start your
energy thing and then you can take it
over that's the thing about you I don't
if no one knows this about Jennifer Love
Hewitt she was on the podcast before but
now I get to see her face even though
it's zoom you are the best looking zoom
guest I've had so far yeah you really
are but to a fault and I know that you
could say attest to this you are one of
the most giving people I've ever met
like everybody I know that you know
you've taught talk we've talked about in
general or just you give everything to
the point where you're so drained and
then sometimes people have taken
advantage of it people end up whatever
in the past I noticed that about you you
just always want to help and do you
sometimes have to like you said with the
kids like it guys I have to start taking
care of myself oh yeah you definitely
can exhaust it I mean I'm a big believer
in that with your time on the planet you
should give everything all you've got
anyway right because what good is it for
you to keep love or kindness or you know
anything that could be valuable to
another person so I'm a big believer is
like hey I haven't you wanted to get
your life better do it you know but but
I do I do think that people like us
every once in a while do you have to set
boundaries and say okay I'm gonna go
back to giving in like ten minutes but I
need needs a like a recess you know I
could be selfish too though I give you a
selfish person I know what how dare you
by the way I know we'll talk about you
know fourth season of nine-one-one
that's pretty cool it seems like
everything you touch it lasts you know
your marriage Ghost Whisperer lasted how
many years five okay don't get cocky
party of five how many years five the
client list only two all right you're
not a success like I thought I'm kidding
come on in 9 1 1 s that know how many
people could say they've had series that
goes 5 years 5 years 4 years 2 years I
had a
go I was on for seven years so that was
great and then - so seven and - but look
you've had some longevity you've had
some good but I don't even like to work
with you is that true do you have a good
reputation is there you think you've a
bridges so I'm oh and I'm also like a
caretaker so I'm always like feeding
people and bringing them in and then you
know being silly and all of that even
when there's lots of drama happening on
camera I try to make it really fun so
yeah you know we are lucky well that
we're so lucky I think you know if you
think about it it's everything you do is
lucky you get to look for instance you
take things for granted like going out
for a hike with your buddy you're lucky
I think everything I do after when I we
could start doing things again I want to
look at my friend I think that's the the
thing I'm gonna do just to remember this
I'm gonna look at them after every walk
ordering and say we're really lucky
that's just something I want to continue
so you don't forget it maybe we start
hash tag we are lucky just to be able we
hashtag we are lucky whatever you do
we're lucky can't we why don't we do a
hash tag we're lucky let's do it
I love it well thanks for being done yet
no way no way um you know I want to
bring up something I know that's reader
to you the first time you came on and
you had just lost your mom and you had
an anxiety attack the night before cuz
you're like oh my god he's gonna bring
it up I'm gonna break down I can't deal
with it and we got through it and she
would have been 75 right yeah in March I
don't know why I just kind of got like I
felt that that emotion in my face and my
nose behind my eyes when I just said it
and I don't you know how are you holding
up you know I'm good I it's interesting
I feel like every year that it goes on I
get more gratitude for how much I
remember I think that was my biggest
panic in the beginning was oh my gosh
was like all this pain gonna overtake
everything that I remember her and am I
just gonna like one day not remember
like am I not gonna remember every
little you know patch of her face or
what it felt like how funny she was what
I wrote and then when I had kids I had
that panic again I was like I don't know
everything about her because this is
gonna be all they have you know and and
I think what's interesting is that every
year that I celebrate her birthday or
every year that I celebrate the day that
she passed I remember something like
extra special about her or and I'm very
conscious of the fact that like the
memories get better and and I'm able to
sit more in the enjoyment of her than in
the sadness of her you know so I feel I
feel lucky for that I feel grateful for
that but it is I mean you know during
this time like I would give anything to
just have her here and talk to her about
this crazy world and I I just thought
the other night I was like I wonder if
she's looking down on us saying WOW
reacted how would she have dealt with
this oh my god first of all she would
have had like some Patricia
know what what's her name okay I was
right I was right I was like [ __ ] she
would have had a secret bunker like two
days after she heard it was even coming
and all of us would be in there together
it would be like one big party she would
have tons of booze and food and she'd
really like use it as an opportunity to
those like the greatest end of the world
party ever I feel like that's what she
would have been doing this time and then
probably panicking silently gosh it's
been a lot I mean I mean you've seen a
lot you've dealt with a lot yeah I lost
my grandfather November and he passed
away at my brother's birthday on
Thanksgiving yeah I know I know and it
was everything I was definitely the
hardest loss but you know it's one of
those things were if anybody's lost I've
everybody's lost someone or you will its
life it's just like the thought cycle of
life this is just what's gonna happen
but with my grandfather with all sylars
I felt like I was losing a piece of him
I was morning almost every every year
that went by I was like four years of
watching this I was oh and especially at
the end in the last computers I felt
like I think I just I felt bad because I
was like I want him to go and it wasn't
because I didn't love him I was like he
would [ __ ] beep he'd scream at us for
allowing him to live like this
he would not he'd be like what he would
have what are we doing what is this
and I was like god I want to take him to
Oregon my grandmother would never do it
I would never say it but I want to take
an organ and put him out of his misery
and let him just go on the next journey
or whatever that is whatever you believe
because I was like I love him so much I
can't see this is not the man I knew and
know you know so it was very hard for me
but I thought I had grieved I thought I
had those moments of those bouts of
crying and emotion and then all of a
sudden he passed away and boy when I
just when you think you're done mourning
it it was almost like you went from
first to sixth gear in a [ __ ] Porsche
you just jerked you back in your seat
and you're like oh my gosh and then
there with my grandmother know this is a
reality I just my Uncle Dave said it he
goes know what the worst part I just
can't say hi to him just Kensi hi you
can say hey hey
can't you know what I mean and that's
that's what's again it's like you do get
through the pain you do hat you do get
through it and you have to just honor
them and by living your life as great as
you can as is I believe that I believe
when you're doing all these great things
and the small businesses and singing
with your husband on Instagram and being
a good mom and schooling your kids she's
smiling down this is like this is what
would make her happy you falling apart
she'd be like what the [ __ ] are you
doing get it together
yeah she definitely would she's she's
all for she was always for and and was
the biggest advocate for choosing your
best life while you have it and and so I
tried to do that for her and I try to
inspire that back to you know my kids
and my friends and everything yeah it's
a it's a it's true I really think I feel
like I know if you thought this too but
because I have been grieving for seven
years now I don't know when I ever won't
be grieving her but I keep thinking of
the people who are this is such a heavy
thing to say it but I keep thinking of
the people who are dying right now whose
loved ones don't even get to say goodbye
or can't get in that hospital for that
last moment or can't throw them a
funeral or can't do that and I just keep
thinking like maybe this is nothing you
don't want a name like my grief is
nothing compared to that and it's such
an extraordinary time in that way and
we're losing so many people and they're
they're going without
without that last moment yeah like you
can't even go very low people can't go
to funerals dancing in the last dying
moment it's harder I couldn't even
imagine couldn't even imagine for my
grandmother
and at the same time you know I'm also
grateful that my grandfather isn't
around for this dinner you know in a
home in a memory facility or home
whatever you wanna call it but like he
because I know my grandmother it would
destroy her she'd go no I'm going there
I'm everyday she had to be with him even
if he didn't remember anybody she would
be there she didn't care what it was she
didn't want him to live so huh yeah
that's tough getting dark
you know you posted something I think he
posted something you said get into the
habit of asking yourself does this
support the life I'm trying to create
does this support the life I'm trying to
create so when you say that is that the
work you're doing is that the decision
what decisions what made you say that
and you like find your tribe whether
that's like your little family that you
have you know put together and that you
add you know friends onto or if it's
just friends whatever it is that is like
you're your tribe but then I think you
kind of go okay so with these people in
mind in my life what is it that I want
to do like what what is it that if it
all ended tomorrow hopefully but if it
all did what it what is it that I want
to take with me and go I did that like
it did that I I put that out there I was
that to people you know whatever it is
and and so I I do really try right now
to to like support the life that I went
great like I really do try to do that I
try to I want joy I want to I want to
act because it's a part who I am and
it's what I loved to do and I love to
connect with people that way through
that camera on that show however I can
you know do that I want to be a great
mom I want my kids to constantly feel
safe and feel joy I want my friends to
feel that I'm value add in her life and
I just want to try to like live in the
good moments and brush off the bag
like that's just kind of what I do and
so I just don't really let anything in
my life right now that doesn't support
that I just don't I don't like new
people in my life that don't support
those ideas I don't spend time on things
really that don't support those ideas
and and it it brings clarity like it
just I think if you kind of figure out
what you really want your life to be
it's always gonna add them flow this was
definitely not a part of what I was
hoping to create this this whole world
is right now but in the time that I'm
living in it I'm creating what I want
like I'm having a great time this with
my family and I'm closer with my kids
and my husband and I are watching fun
shows and having good conversations I'm
getting to talk to you and I'm putting
positivity out for people and you know
I'm doing what I want to do and I just
think I think you have to fight to do
that I really do but I think once you
start sending that message to people
over and over again like oh yeah that
doesn't fit in this in this thing I'm
creating it goes away eventually and
they stop asking and you you really do
find that the opportunities that come to
the people that are around you support
what you're trying to to be and do in
your life and it's really nice inside
you use brought to you by fair harbor I
don't know what to say don't fast
forward is what I'll say right now I
love the the story I love the product
they have this this liner a boxer-brief
liner in the shorts they're incredibly
comfortable I have worn them every day
since these guys became my sponsor I'm
gonna stand up and show you them again
I'm not kidding I wear them all the time
you're not gonna feel anything like them
trust me buy the shorts get them you're
gonna get a big discount when I read it
at the end 2.5 million plastic bottles
are recycled they're shorts are made
from recycled bottles they had this
lining in them that I've never seen any
shorts and he's short have I wear these
all day I don't even need underwear
because they have this lining it's like
you're wearing underwear and it's light
I go jogging I'm not gonna lie to you I
go walking fair harbour replaced all
mesh lining with their supersoft
built-in boxer-brief liner that's what I
just said and it is softer than anything
you've ever felt before swimming
exercise lounging and even sleeping you
won't take the shorts off and they're
right fair harbour is now offering a
kid's line so the younger guys can say
goodbye to mesh lining now to fair
harbor makes products for you to enjoy
the places you love while protecting
those places at the same time 20% off
for everyone listening right now head
over to fair harbor clothing comm use
the code inside 20 for 20 percent off
that's inside 20 say goodbye to mesh
lining forever can you actually use this
excuse with your kids can you say hey
remember that whole Cove 'add thing you
know the corona remember when mommy was
home for a couple months
mommy's gonna [ __ ] off now so but just
remember I was there for you but now not
going you can't do that can you you
can't take like a month off and say I'll
see ya I was there for you two months
two straight months which was a lot of
hours add those hours up sweetie no go
back to school I'm the one saying how's
the guys do you look back like you know
on your career cuz you had a big career
you've done a ton of stuff you're you're
famous you got really famous fast
everything kind of changed your whole
life so when you're that young and
you're that like oh my god there's got
to be that feeling of like sometimes
like I'm a star you have I'm sure like
I'm a star everybody knows me I'm not
singing you're not humble but lit here
you hear me out
cuz so it's like okay I'm doing this I'm
want you know this and does there come a
point where like I want to be did you
did you think you wanted to be a star
and you want to be famous
you want to keep getting more of more
famous or was there some point where
you're like I don't care about that
anymore
my family my honestly like this is a
real thing like you know you're on 9/11
this is a great show right this is you
love it you love being a part of it you
know it's a it's a what do you call it
when it's a lot of people in the show
it's a it ensemble and you know you held
shows you've been the lead on shows do
you think I don't need to have my own
show right now again or now I'm not
saying you hear me out again I'm not
done I could I don't need to have that I
don't need to be the star of this I
don't need to be in this I don't need to
reinvent myself or prove myself any more
than I have in my career you know
because these are things that going on
everybody's head I've had things where I
haven't had any success compared to the
amount of success you had in my mind I
just feel like you know I am just trying
to honestly and I know a lot of people
hate the word so I'm not gonna use it
like that the word happy but like trying
to do that that's what I'm getting at
with this whole thing you said about
does this support the life I'm trying to
create and so hey I want to feel good I
just want to feel good physically and
mentally those are the two most
important things I'm oh I just feel good
and then I could be the best person and
then feeling good you know those kind of
go together in terms of I want to be a
continue to be a great good person I
don't am a great person I think I'm good
at times I'm like we also talked to each
other last time and I asked you if you
loved yourself and you said huh I I
don't and it was a kind of like a know
in a way and then I said the Rob my
engineer ago you love yourself he goes
no like what and then I realized wait I
don't know if I love myself II so
there's three people in there sitting
there going what is that I know this is
the worst question because it's more of
like a Ritz where it's more like just
spitballing but when is enough enough
when is it like and what do you do to
love yourself more so I've really been
working on the love myself thing since
our last conversation because I went
home after our conversation and I felt
so good about our chat and seeing you
and just like it was fun and it was good
and I
I felt like we had had done what I was
hoping to do that day would just show
people who I really am I'm like what my
thoughts and feelings really are not
some journalists like writing it down no
you did did you know anything like I
really got disgusted
it's got to be myself and until I felt
really good about it but I also felt
really sad because it was like I left
them listening and and I left him with
this idea that like I don't like myself
but it was the truth and we were telling
the truth so much of the truth that day
that I was like I can't do anything and
a dude crossed my mind I was like I
wonder if I should calling him and just
thank him so like take that part out so
that I don't want people to feel that
way and I didn't want people to think
that I was like sad or didn't you know
whatever and then I was like no don't do
that because that's where it was for
like you were being your authentic self
and your authentic self does not like
themselves right now so to update you
still out there and I'm working on it
really hard and I think I'm working on
it the only way that I know how to do it
is to give myself
Oh grace I've been really trying to use
kind words to myself and I have been
trying to be supportive of just like
whatever it is that I'm going through at
the moment it's anxiety I know I'm not
hard on myself anymore about having
anxiety I'm just like [ __ ] anxiety
they're like let's just get through it
there you go that's me whatever I've
been trying to be good to myself during
this time I feel like I need to
quarantine from my fridge because I've
been eating my feelings for sure certain
days we all have you know but I've been
trying not to be hard on myself about
that either been trying to be like okay
that's that's this little span of three
days now zip it up and you know get it
together so I'm still working on it I'm
definitely still working on it and I
think that I'm getting there I had an
interesting moment with my daughter
about two and a half months ago and I
was not feeling good at that day just
about myself look wise whatever and I
said something out loud to myself in the
mirror are not really realizing that
she's standing that close to me and she
said stop would you say I don't remember
honestly I don't remember it was
something about not feeling great
whatever and she said mommy please don't
talk about yourself that way and I was
like oh okay I said I'm so sorry you
know what you're right I shouldn't have
done that and then later like a few
hours later she went back to it and she
was like
mommy if you feel that way about
yourself and I look like you then do you
feel that way about me too
and I was like oh I'm gonna kill me like
it literally till I start crying
instantly and and I had to apologize to
her and it was a moment where I was like
it's important for the reasons that you
and I talked about for you to like
yourselves but then when you're a parent
and you're trying to make these people
be them their best selves and to try to
like hold them up ensure them up as much
as possible to give them as much
confidence in who they are because the
world is going to knock that down later
and different moments boys and girls are
gonna break up you know and in school
like it's gonna happen like they're
gonna have an ox their confidence
thankfully in this stage of life it's
our job to make them feel so good but
part of that is them knowing that you
like yourself and my daughter was very
aware of the fact that I do not like
myself yet in that moment anyway it was
really hard that is that's really strong
because I when you were talking I
started thinking if I ever have a kid I
know that's gonna happen but I can
imagine myself going listen you're
already smarter than me I'm not very
smart you're smart and no matter what
you do I'm gonna be proud of you and
look I am yeah and you gotta be careful
I guess she was really sensitive that
mom didn't like her looks or didn't like
her and isn't it amazing how those even
the littlest things that you wouldn't
think oh she won't be affected by that
she was profoundly affected by that even
so to come to you later and then say
mommy when you say that you're saying
that to me cuz I look like you and it's
what first of all your kids a genius by
the way my kid probably wouldn't say
that I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding
so yeah we get ahead of ourselves
no but I think when I can be genuine and
altruistic and I'm doing things not
thinking that oh the cameras
people are watching when I do things
that are just innately lack of a better
word organic they're just when I can
just do something selfless and not think
of it it's just something I have to do
to help someone to make someone laugh to
whatever it is that's when I'm happy
when opment that's when I love myself
you know last night I called uh by the
way I do a lot of [ __ ] that I'm like I
hate you I hate you I hate you so that's
nice when you could say aloha but when
those moments like last night one of my
buddies he's 16 he's got terminal cancer
he's I met him at the wrong with Donnell
house which donated if you want it's an
awesome place and I just became friends
with him and his family I went to see
them we're writing it we're gonna write
a song together and Jessica I'm gonna
call Preston and just getting on the
phone with him and just laughs in 30
minutes goodbye and we're talking about
girls and we're talking about you know
his treatments and you know some of the
[ __ ] he has to deal with and we're
talking about you know just life and I'm
like you know that this is cool I didn't
say let's do this because this I did it
cuz I really wanted to do it and I cared
and I liked him and I I enjoyed it and
it it just was meaningful so I feel like
I'm at my best when I could just be just
absolutely genuine just and it doesn't
always come off
you know I'm feel like begging people
please listen to the podcast please
subscribe to your friends you feel like
oh my god I'm whoring myself out but you
know I love it but I love it but at the
same time when I could do something for
others that just feels just feels
authentic and real that's that's those
moments of love but that's the same like
I know the days that I feel best is when
I have either been around people who've
allowed me to be authentic or tapped
into something authentic for myself and
been able to give that to other
well I mean that's the beautiful part
not that I will say I think is one
really beautiful ripple effect of
everything that's been going on right
now is I I feel like we are seeing the
most genuine authentic version of people
the ones that are like really bold
enough to give it you know on social
media or in the news or on TV or
whatever and and I hope that that stays
I really hope that that stays I hope
that people are seeing that like we all
really like you just as you are without
all of the without all of the stuff you
know none yeah it's it's beautiful to
see like the people that I have that I
have seen doing that it's really um it's
really nice and I hope that I hope it
keeps some of that don't go changing the
try to please mazing never change the
color of your hair you should call your
beard color my beard pink what should I
color it purple a purple beard then I'd
be like that baseball player I'm fine
I'm looking up your name because I want
to play something this is of you and
your husband this is what you do over
the quarantine although maybe this is
nice
this is you singing and you're playing
with your hubby you sound like a country
star star come on that's beautiful yeah
yeah I try to I do these instructors I
do insta live and we do a thing where
was like just pick a song and I don't
know it and I'll just go on there oh
that let's try it sometimes I'll bomb
sometimes like oh wow I did it but I
just don't care and I just do it and
it's a lot of fun I want it yeah there
should be some kind of show like that
guy that'd be fun like hosting some kind
of like sing-along incredible like he is
not a trained musician but I'll be like
hey babe I want you to learn this song
I'm within like 15 minutes how do you do
that me I can play the guitar like this
much of this much he's just it's it's
incredible I love to watch him do it
it's really fun but your voice is that
your thing that you do that's your tick
when you get anxiety
all right well sorry stop dancing stop
doing it
I'm gonna ask you these are called [ __ ]
talking with Rosenbaum these are from my
patrons who I love dearly and all the
patrons who support the podcast are just
exceptional it's just beautiful thing
and I love all of you but this is
questions for you and you can answer
them quickly you don't have to you know
go on and on about this [ __ ] I did not
say that did not say that I love you
little Lisa if you could have one
superpower what would it be superpower
it would be to hug people okay that
would be your superpower I could hug
people and not get it
that'd be I said that's it that's a cool
thing my I think mine would be it's not
for me it's not for nevermind I was just
that he old people anyway Raj
rise rising no nose great a music
producer wants to create an album of
duets with you and me Jay look what are
some songs you you that we would like to
record on the album mine would be
probably endless love oh sweet song I
always imagine him killing himself
though in the movie I'm sorry j-jake M
what is your expressive love language
and how do you use it to express your
love for those around you selfless acts
and then I like to just know that
matters
do you know what you don't good answer
Nikko P good old Nikko helps with the
podcast good man good kid Zack is there
something people seem to understand
about him if so what is it I think
people believe that because I'm positive
that that means that I am happy all of
the time and that is a misconception who
feels things very deeply but always
believes that when something bad is
happening
that good will come so positive it
doesn't necessarily mean the time that
you're happy the whole time yeah you
know I sometimes think about that too
it's like oh my god he's such a happy
person I'm like would you really look
the real person can't go up and go no
I'm having a shitty day what leave me
alone oh my god I'm just a mess I just
know it's too even no you don't want to
see that nobody wants to see that
so you try to keep your [ __ ] to yourself
or with close friends or someone you
love and the rest of it no one needs to
see I mean unless you're in a reality
show
Jamie H what was one of your most
defining moments as an adult that helped
shape you changed
almost everything about me into like a
new hyper-focused
trait like it just kind of everything
just went like very clear and but it's
also brought a lot of really beautiful
things like getting married and having
kids and believing that you know I could
do that and and and still have a career
and you know all of those things so I
would say that all right
boy did I tell you look great thank you
so much you're very nice how are you
talking about you were talking I
actually was looking at you go she's
beautiful thank you just I'm not you
know obvious I'm not hitting on you I
love you I just I'm saying I really just
I just noticed Beauty I was like wow
you're just you're eloquent but you're
also like you're just pretty thank you
you're welcome
you went from child star to sexualize
leading lady in a short period of time
how did that affect your self-image and
the way you saw people treating you I
shouldn't read like that I'm just
confused as to why people were kind of
looking at me that way
I'm thinking of me that way cuz again
like I'm a very sort of dorky silly
person and don't think of myself as like
a sexy whatever later in life it made me
feel extraordinarily uncomfortable for
my seventeen year old self and so I you
know spent some time working on that but
but at the time that it was happening
you know I just remember thinking what's
wrong with people why do they feel this
way about me but but yeah it was fine
alright few more questions Joshua age
what is something important you've
learned during your career that would
have benefited you if you'd learned it
earlier in your professional life that
autumn screaming yummy smile suddenly
kids are having like a full like outside
the guy is everybody okay
I'm gonna hide in here yeah deal with
the husband do it I actually don't know
I feel like yeah I don't I don't know I
want to get from an answer but I don't
know I don't know what I would say you
know just to answer this question for me
right maybe that maybe that that you you
don't have to worry so much that you're
not gonna get like your next job like
it'll be there like you kind of have a
career like I feel like if I had worried
less about that I would have enjoyed the
stuff that I was getting to do more like
now I don't worry about it as much and
it will work then that's gonna suck but
you know whatever like I was the things
my life but at the time when I was
younger I just was so hyper focused and
worried all the time yeah I think so I
think that I did that too just like and
I think I just like to to enjoy the
moment I would say that to any younger
self enjoying now not tomorrow not the
just now this moment whatever it is just
right now me and Jennifer Lisa is there
anything you've always wanted to do in
your career why career that you just
haven't gotten around to I've always
wanted to do a musical TV show or movie
thing all the time like a Glee or a
crazy ex-girlfriend or that Zoe's
extreme playlist that's on TV right now
like I was given anything that is
something what would you do emily s what
would you do if if you weren't acting
what I do I feel like I would be like I
would just have been crusty she's got
Judit what would you like people to
remember about you say it's always the
question there was that's cheesy no no
seriously that's it I think it's a legit
question like I have a little old woman
not to be McCobb was looking at your
gravestone goes oh that Jennifer Love
Hewitt she was just full of lights full
of light like you it remember that I was
really happy like that I just really
enjoyed my life I like that I think you
do love yourself a little more you do
you think you see yeah I could see I
could just see that you're just you're
just like you said you're being kind to
you
if you're giving yourself like hey you
just have to it's like you could punish
yourself all day I could sit here all
day and go why did you do that
that was selfish why'd you do that why
don't you get up and do that well you
could sit there all day and tell about
but it's about what you're doing next
and how you gotta learn it from that so
if you could have those moments those
intermittent moments and hopefully make
those moments a little more than the
other moments
yeah that's creating good habits and
getting rid of the bad ones I saw it saw
its work in progress dude I am fugly
some of those I think I've done some
days I'm like I'm giving up and some
days I I do some days I just go I'm done
what am I not like with my life like
that get help immediately I'm saying I
just feel like what's the point what's
the [ __ ] point why am i why am I even
going on the cuts not gonna you could
sit there and go down and where am i why
am i even that project nothin that's all
don't buy anything if they buy it do not
even play
what am I doing here look I love this
I'm so glad you did this and you know
what it's not a bad pickup line it's
like hey I'm quarantine so are you why
don't we talk face-to-face all right
look this has been amazing thank you for
doing this again I hope you'll come back
again I think you have fun yeah I love
you too I do and I hope too when this is
over I could come and hang out with the
fam I want I want to come hang out I
really do honestly I'd love that thank
you for allowing me to be inside of you
again jennifer Love Hewitt and besides
nine-one-one is that you got the family
and you got 9-1-1 right brilliant but
you're up you're up for doing other
stuff though right on you know hmm
say I could do like small parts on other
shows I think I don't know sorry is for
sissies do pet packin go oh my god those
10 years ago all right I love you thank
you again I'm
but I want crystals texting me and we'll
talk about t-shirts maybe and I love you
give my love to your family I mean come
on I hope you like that one I hope you
enjoyed it
Jennifer is just such a fantastic woman
she is just as you can tell a great
mother great any uh man I just love that
woman I really do
she's fantastic I want to give a shout
out to my patrons and the first we're
gonna read a fan letter all right this
is from Jennifer that Rosie let me start
off by saying thank you for doing the
inside of your podcast at least I'm not
alone struggling with anxiety no no
you're not
I love the second interview that you did
with Stephen Amell I never thought he
had issues with anxiety and I gave him
kudos for him returning back to finish
the interview after he had an anxiety
attack if you guys know I suffer from
anxiety to which I don't tell a lot of
people because I fear of how they will
think of me or treat me I'm surprised my
husband wanted to marry me and is still
with me for 24 years because you're
awesome sorry I responded too early my
mom was my rock and my best from when I
was younger she had always been there
for me through thick and thin when I was
2 years old my mom was worried that I
was not responding when people would
talk to me and fought for me when the
doctors another specialist told her that
I would never learn to read or write
there was nothing they could do for me
they suggested to her to put me in a
special home and she would not have that
she would not have that and kept looking
for answers she finally went to a
specialist that dealt with hearing and
he did some testing he discovered that I
was hard of hearing
HOH he fitted me with hearing aids and I
was able to hear plus I read lips
once I was fitted with hearing aids I
still struggle with talking did not talk
till I was 7 years old so I had to work
with a speech therapist for my
elementary and middle school kids or
middle school years sorry that helped me
a lot because now people that know me
say I never shut up and I tell them I am
making up time for five years of not
talking laughs out loud I did struggle
through my school years with teachers
not wanting to cooperate with putting me
in front of the class so I can read
their lips because of my maiden name
Walton yes it's like the TV show they
wanted to seat us alphabetically A
through Z not see through a plus the
kids in school were not so kind either
they would
me alien because I had trouble with my
speech dating I was not normal did not
fit in my mom's determination to get me
to help I need it through school and
getting teachers to cooperate had helped
me through the years growing up I do
miss her but she's in my heart my
anxiety has gotten worse as I get older
my relationship with my dad is not great
but I've accepted that because if it
wasn't for my mom fighting for me I
wouldn't be where I am today
I still struggle so I am so hard on
myself if I make mistakes don't always
have good self-esteem and feel like I
don't always belong now I'm working from
home due to this pandemic I'm grateful
that I still have a job due to my
company health care being essential but
miss the interaction of my co-workers
right now I work from home July till
July 13th my fear is that they will
change it to the rest of the year for us
working from home I hope not but have to
wait and see I apologize for the long
email to read but wanted to let you know
my listening to your podcasts have
listened to them all since March 2020
has made me smile laugh and cry I hope
to meet you someday in the future you
will if you come back to do a Smallville
nights in Columbus Ohio I'm sure we will
keep up the great work doing your
podcast patreon and Instagram life
videos I really enjoy them also enjoy
watching here dogs when you include them
your patron Jennifer it's beautiful
Jennifer you're amazing we've talked
before via patron or and I think we did
a zoom I like how you you know you face
so much adversity and so much pain in
your life and it it's nice to hear that
you're plugging away and you work on
yourself and you know your husband's
with you because you're awesome their
husbands with you because he needs you I
think people gravitate towards you
because you're a good person so you
never feel like you know you know worthy
or people are looking at you funny I
mean we all feel that I feel like people
are judging me all the time every
interview I think they're thinking god
you suck at interviewing believe me
Jennifer I appreciate your email your
your letter I printed it out off hello
at inside of you podcast calm so thank
you thank you for that I appreciate all
your fan mail and your messages
don't go unread
I do read them sometimes it takes me a
while to share them with you if I choose
to share them why don't I give my
patrons a shout out because I love each
and every one this is the inside a
patron Nancy D Mary bee Leah s Tricia F
sarahfey Yukiko Jill EEB Ryan H Lauren
Cheney kopi berry I actually it's Barry
L hello Barry how often do I do that
Angelina G Jerry W Kevin R Emily K Bob
be Robert B Jason W Kristen K Andrew see
Alison L Jason Dheeraj Sean W Joshua D
Emily s cjp rocks raccoons samantha am
hamza be Jennifer Anne Stacey beat
Carlita Vanessa in the sky ream Jennifer
ass Janelle be neil w tabitha see
Kimberly e Melissa see Mike e Jake M
Marissa and Catherine M Jack s still up
in the upstairs there playing video
games Jack Carlie male hello Judith D
Ramiro Chris F Sarah F Chad W Leon P
Darla W Jackie P Rodrigo s great rakin I
messed that name every time you saw in
the questions I did that on the bonus
material on the patron rake and raishin
Travis beer a a Maya P megan d de Mario
Tina J Jennifer see Maddie s Tiffany L
Kendrick F Ashley E and Kelly W I
couldn't do this without you you guys
you guys are unbelievably supportive you
know I mess Agyei message to everybody
and respond to everybody but I kind of
randomly throughout the days go and go
oh and I just respond and you know it's
hard but it's it's it's addicting too
addictive addictive yeah whatever I
wasn't great in word power but I loved
it
once again left on Laurel you can still
get the album on iTunes you can order an
inside of you online store or Spotify
I'm gonna do another stage it and
announce it right now I didn't announce
at the beginning June 20th at 2:00 p.m.
go to stage at 2:00 p.m. for all those
Europeans and all the people over there
and the
side of the world a 2 p.m. chillin
Saturday June 20th in a 6 p.m. show so
we're gonna do another one about a month
from now Rob and I so it'll be Michael
Rosenbaum and Rob Danson and we'll play
some more covers and some some more
originals and maybe a left a little song
or to see how we feel I'm sure we'll
play two at least and I don't forget the
new patreon where have all the good
horror movies gone make sure you check
it out
me and Jon Heder on patreon it's an
exclusive I had a weird conversation
with my friend Harland and I was like I
just feel like the person you know when
you're doing something right you know
when you're doing something wrong you
could feel innately
so it's just like whatever that calling
is whatever you know your body speaks to
you when you're not doing something cool
or something that's just a little bit
yeah you could feel it in your gut
unless you're you know complete I don't
know
serial killer but I'm just trying to
listen to my gut more I'm trying to
listen and say hey that's not right or
hey do more of that that's what your
soul seeks you know so I'm just saying
go with your gut man be a good person or
continue to be a good person and don't
be hard on yourself when you f up lord
knows I F up so thank you for allowing
to be inside each and every one of you
guys I look forward to next week and
thank you my guest jennifer Love Hewitt
thank you for all my to all my patrons
and look at me on the Instagram live
will do one soon and of course the
patrons the YouTube private life okay
[Music]